okay so this video will be an overview
of fermentation if you're looking for a
more detailed explanation if you read in
the description box below there will be
a link to a more detailed version of
fermentation that I've previously made
so this diagram kind of summarizes what
we're going to be talking about today
with the process of fermentation so
let's look at this in a little more
detail okay so this video is really
gonna be a lot about making energy and
sometimes our cells make energy when
oxygen is present that is called aerobic
respiration and sometimes our cells have
to make energy without oxygen
that's called anaerobic respiration but
as far as making energy goes it all
starts with the light calluses so in my
cell here is a molecule of glucose and
through the process of glycolysis the
glucose were broken down into a couple
molecules of pyruvate again that's a
that's what happens during glycolysis
well what happens next depends there's
two pathways one pathway leads directly
into the mitochondria and one pathway
the pyruvates kind of stay in the
cytoplasm well in the mitochondria this
is the aerobic pathway if there's oxygen
present the pyruvate Center the
mitochondria and then that's when the
Krebs cycle will occur followed by the
electron transport chain so when you add
up the energy or the ATP created through
glycolysis plus the Krebs cycle plus the
electron transport chain you get about
36 molecules of ATP but sometimes
oxygens not available and let's follow
the arrow to the right let's follow the
anaerobic pathway this is the process
that happens when there's no oxygen this
is the process known as fermentation the
pyruvates will go through fermentation
and be broken down into lactic acid or
ethanol depending on the type of
fermentation and when fermentation is
finished a molecule abbreviated nad will
be will be created in the end
D helps to break down a new molecule of
glucose to restart glycolysis so let's
look at this a little more closely so as
I said a moment ago glycolysis is really
the beginning of this energy making
process and glycolysis is the breakdown
of glucose and this occurs in the
cytoplasm of cells so after a meal the
glucose that you digest enters your
bloodstream and then here's a molecule
of glucose diffusing into a cell into
the cytoplasm of a cell let's zoom on in
and take a closer look and there's the
glucose that ring of six carbons bonded
together in a hexagon form now for
simplicity I've only drawn the glucose
as a ring of six carbons it also has 12
hydrogen's and six oxygens but again for
simplicity I just drew the six carbons
to focus on and to kind of abbreviate
glucose and so what happens well here's
that molecule of glucose that that we
received from our food and it's going to
be broken down by enzymes and I like to
illustrate animated scissors to be
symbolic of enzymes and what the enzymes
will do will break down glucose
molecules and when that happens a couple
molecules of ATP are created this is the
cell's energy this is the kind of the
point of glycolysis is to make these
molecules of ATP notice you also have
two molecules of pyruvate
I've also labeled them the broken pieces
of glucose because once glucose is
broken apart it's not glucose anymore
these broken fragments are called
pyruvate and what happens is if oxygen
is present these pyruvates will go to
the mitochondria where the Krebs cycle
will occur and then the electron
transport chain but this video is gonna
follow what happens when oxygen is not
present the pyruvates are gonna stay in
the cytoplasm and fermentation is gonna
happen
so let's talk about the two kinds of
fermentation the first being lactic acid
fermentation and this is the
fermentation performed by the human body
and other animals such as bears and also
performed by many types of bacteria
after all it's the bacterial species
that do lactic acid fermentation that it
that gives sourdough bread its unique
flavor we also use bacteria to that do
lactic acid fermentation
in the process of fermenting cucumbers
in order to make pickles and we also use
bacteria that the electic acid
fermentation in the production of the
yogurt you know yogurt has a very sour
taste to it and that's because of the
lactic acid produced by the bacteria
that that that do lactic acid
fermentation and so lactic acid
fermentation occurs in the cytoplasm and
it occurs when cells are not receiving
enough oxygen in order to perform the
Krebs cycle and the electron transport
chain and this happens in human cells
particularly in muscle cells and you
might think well how come our cells
aren't getting enough oxygen well in our
animation we have a person you know
running during exercise your muscles
need a lot of ATP because they're
working really really hard so the
solution might be well why doesn't our
cells just take some of the stored
glucose that we have break it down to
make more ATP that way our muscles can
have ATP and it can keep working well
that would be great if oxygen was
abundant however there's a new problem
here during heavy exercise your muscles
are actually oxygen deprived and even
though you're breathing heavy
you're clearly breathing heavy you're
sucking in a lot of oxygen the oxygen is
just not getting to your muscles well
you could stop you could stop your
exercise but that kind of defeats the
purpose you know especially if you're in
the middle of a sporting contest you're
not going to just stop and let the other
team you know run away with the ball
you're gonna keep pushing yourself so we
can't really just
stop we're gonna have to keep going so
the solution is what's called lactic
acid fermentation so let's talk about
this so here's an overview there's the
two pyruvate molecules that we saw
broken that means glycolysis must have
just ended so what happens now that
glycolysis is finished
well those pyruvates both pyruvates are
going to be broken down into lactic acid
and this is what causes muscle soreness
during you know physical exertion and
heavy exercise so there is my animated
scissors representing enzymes and what
they do is they cause this pyruvate to
be broken down into lactic acid and in
the process of doing that a molecule
abbreviated NAD+ is created that's
really important and you'll see why in a
moment
here's another pair of animated scissors
representing enzymes and the other
pyruvate is being broken down into
lactic acid as well but notice what's
really important here is the formation
of these nad plus molecules this is a
molecule by the name of nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide and what nad is
responsible for is restarting glycolysis
and so one thing I want to stress is
that zero zero
molecules of ATP were created
that's not why fermentation is important
fermentation is important because it
makes nad which can restart glycolysis
so now that lactic acid fermentation is
finished the lactic acid is released as
a waste and the molecules of nad are
left over in the cytoplasm here comes a
new molecule of glucose and so now we
see why the nad is important is it can
help to break down that glucose to
restart glycolysis and so how much
eighty was ATP was created through
fermentation zero
but now that we have a new molecule of
glucose
how much ATP will be created through
glycolysis what the na DS will do is
help break down glucose there for two
more molecules of ATP can be created and
this amount of energy can help to
prolong your physical exertion to help
prolong your exercise that you're
performing
well let's take a break from talking
fermentation let's just focus for a
quick moment on you know recovering from
a hard exercise after exercise you're
probably really sore and so one great
way to help recover from that is through
massage whether you use a professional
masseuse or you use a foam roller and
you just roll your muscles over that
foam pad that you see in the picture
massage is a great way to help your
muscles recover from exercise as is you
know eating foods like bananas which are
high in potassium potassium is really
important in your muscles ability to
stretch and contract so after a hard
workout eating a banana is a great way
to help recover also properly hydrating
not just during your activity but before
the activity even begins you don't want
to be dehydrated and then you know run a
race so properly hydrating before during
and after is crucial in your recovery
from your activity and finally a post
stretch you know a lot of teams and a
lot of people know to do a pre stretch
before the activity but sometimes we
don't do the post stretch and stretching
afterwards is just a great way to help
recover from a hard workout well let's
get back to talking about fermentation
well there's another type of
fermentation the other one is called
alcoholic fermentation and this is the
fermentation often performed by yeast
which is a type of fungus and even some
plants and so through the actions of
yeast were able to create alcoholic
beverages and various types of bread I
mentioned sourdough earlier is created
from a type of bacteria that does lactic
acid fermentation but most breads are
created through alcoholic fermentation
and so this type of fermentation also
occurs in the cytoplasm of let's say
yeast cells and so what happens is well
here's a couple pyruvate that means
glycolysis must have just ended so now
that glycolysis is finished and we have
these two molecules of pyruvate what
happens next
well those pyruvates are going to be
broken down into an alcohol by the name
of ethanol also some carbon dioxide will
be created so in order to break down the
pyruvates we need some enzymes and
there's my animated scissors and in the
breakdown of pyruvate three things were
created Evon all which is an alcohol a
molecule of nad and some carbon dioxide
waste was created and so again as we
said earlier it's that nad that's gonna
allow glycolysis to restart let's
actually see that one more time with the
pyruvate on the right there's our enzyme
that's gonna help break down the
pyruvate and notice how three molecules
are created a molecule of ethanol the
molecule another molecule of nad and
another carbon dioxide was created again
I want to stress zero ATP was created
but alcoholic fermentation is important
because of the nad that was created
and so what happens now that the alcohol
has been created it's released as a
waste as is the carbon dioxide released
as a waste and in comes another molecule
of glucose this glucose with the help of
nad and various enzymes can be broken
down during the act of glycolysis so
again if I were to ask you how much ATP
was created through fermentation well
the answer is zero but now that a new
molecule of glucose has Tate has been
taken in now that the cell has some nad
if I were to ask how much ATP can be
created through glycolysis the answer
should be two molecules of ATP so as we
wrap up I just want to do a compare and
contrast lactic acid fermentation on the
top alcoholic fermentation on the bottom
they're both gonna start with a molecule
of glucose and in lactic acid
fermentation what happens first is
glycolysis that glucose molecule is
broken down into two pyruvates through
the process of glycolysis what what
happens next
those two pyruvate molecules undergo
lactic acid fermentation and are broken
down into two molecules of lactic acid
in the process of doing this a couple
molecules of nad
the NAD helps to restart glycolysis and
break down another molecule of glucose
well now let's look at alcoholic
fermentation on the bottom it two starts
with a molecule of glucose and also
glycolysis will occur and that glucose
molecule will be broken down into two
pyruvates well what happens with those
two pyruvates they go through alcoholic
fermentation and the two pyruvates are
broken down into two molecules of
ethanol and two molecules of carbon
dioxide in the process of that occurring
couple molecules of NADH
the NAD helps to break down a new
glucose molecule during glycolysis and I
hope you're seeing the importance of
fermentation even though 0 ATP is
created fermentation
allows glycolysis to restart and every
time glycolysis is performed the cells
will benefit by making two molecules of
ATP so there you have it there's a
hopefully an overview of fermentation if
you're in my class you know pause the
video and try to answer these questions
I'm happy to check your answers before
class or after class one day thanks for
watching